my plan is through those things which is
really just a kind of what my ideal for
today is that we get through this stuff
we're not in a rush so we ask questions
but when we get through it we're just
going to break and I'm going to
encourage you to do some hacking to
explore the note books if you haven't
already to get a more hands-on look at
the material we're also you could just
dive into homework 1 we should certainly
make sure that your system is set up
he's going to be here today without
feeling like you're ready to just work
productively on the problems so a bunch
of the teaching here in the room and
then we're gonna have a setup where you
could this is the to get your system
work until Monday afternoon to discover
that you don't
[Music]
okay can you just let me see okay where
we left off is that I had planted the
seed for glove basically I said some
nice words about this paper I am a big
fan of this paper
and I gave you the intuition and also
here's some other practical details
about implementations that you might use
so we're using methods by and large
there's also a C implementation and I
think in a in a minute I'm going to show
you kind of a reference implementation
that is very very slow but it's kind of
what you would do to just naively
implement the algorithm and I think that
there's a real pedagogical value to see
exactly how those computations we go so
we're gonna plan said that but not I'm
not saying that you should use it for
anything beyond study so here's how I
introduced glove I gave at the top there
what they present as kind of their ideal
objective which is that for row
representation or a row embedding W sub
I its dot product with a column
embedding W sub K that's the primary
term and then you have to bias terms and
the idea is that that should be equal to
the log of the current score currents
probability or at least like it's
proportional to it they kind of dive
down further so they're ideal
reconstruction of what that dot product
is is that it should be the log of the
co-occurrence probability and they
define that
it's probability as the log of the
co-occurrence count minus the log of the
row probability and if you do allow that
the rows and columns and this matrix
might be different so you'd want to not
just concentrate in for normalizing on
that row but also on the column I think
you get this expression here which isn't
in the paper but I think it's certainly
in the spirit of the paper because even
for their matrices the rows and columns
could be different and so then you've
reconstructed the co-occurrence
probability as the log of the
co-occurrence minus the product of the
two the row in the column and what I
just pointed out to you is that you know
that's PMI that is certain like in some
sense that's the literal calculation of
PMI and you can certainly see that what
we're what we're getting from this
picture is that glog is built on that
PMI intuition it's not the same as PMI
of course because we're learning we're
learning regularized reduced dimensional
representations
whereas PMI is just a reading of the
entire count matrix but I really like
this as an entry point to glove when you
think of glove you could think of it
first and foremost as capitalizing on
that core insight that's where we left
off there are a few more details for the
paper though that I think are really
important for why blood work so well so
again I just repeated the original glove
objective up here at the top what they
actually argue for is a weighted version
of it which you see down here and the
new piece is like at its core you have
that dot product again of the row in the
column you have to bias terms for the
row in the column and then you subtract
out the log co-occurrence it's
additionally weighted by this function f
so f is a function of the counts and
what it's doing essentially is kind of
flattening out and rescaling
those count values so f of X it's a
general function defined here you set x
max the default and the spirit of the
paper is to set it at 100 so a count of
100 so if X is less than that max value
you set it as
portion of that max with an exponential
scaling here of alpha and if it's equal
or greater to the max you just set it to
one yeah as I sit down here alpha is
typically 0.75 and x max is typically
100 I think that's fine reasonable
default I'm gonna suggest that you think
a little bit about that though but is
that clear so far that's kind of the
whole model right when you think of them
you should think of that dot product of
row and column with some bias terms and
then subtracting out the log
co-occurrence make sense plus every we
know that the global hyper parameters so
there are really three the first is just
the dimensionality of the learned
representation you get to set that and
consider that any number and you can
imagine that setting it at larger values
is going to give you more capacity to
learn but also take more time and
everything else so that's kind of
something that you play with for all of
these models x max is gonna flatten out
all the high counts and the idea what a
plant there is that you might reflect on
that value and the way you might think
about it is for my count matrix what
percentage of the values are actually at
or above that threshold if it's a
hundred percent of them for some reason
then picking X maps to 100 is going to
turn your entire matrix into a bunch of
ones that's certainly not going to be
good right that's unlikely that you
would have account matrix that was that
dense
but what percentage is it and what are
you doing to your matrix when you
flatten out all maybe oh what's a large
percentage of them of the values so you
could think about that and then you can
also think about alpha which is going to
control how much scaling you do for
counts that are below your max and here
I've given an example so the the
incoming row vector for this F I'm
defined with the default is 199 75 10
and 1 and once I've applied this reading
it looks like this so obviously the
magnitudes are much different one point
9.81 0.18 and 0.03 so you're doing
something very important to this space
when you do this really make sense this
is a new slide that I added I recognize
that it's very dense it's kind of there
for a reference but let me give you a
guided tour of it and let me step back
and just say I was thinking about other
ways that we might at an analytic level
get a deeper understanding of club we
have the PMI insight I've shown you the
globe objective but what else could we
do and what I thought is when I
motivated LSA before I gave you this
example is gnarly and wicked and my
motivation motivation for showing you
that was these are two words that are
similar and semantically they're both
kind of positive slang terms maybe but
they're unlikely to occur with each
other because they're kind of from
different dialects that was the idea and
I pitch to you was that LSA has the
capacity to recognize that they are
similar despite never co-occurring
because they have other neighbors in
common because they may over occur
together with awesome and less than you
would expect with terrible and as a
result LSA is able to capture that
insight right that was one of the
motivations there and I thought how does
glove do this because glove by its
nature because of this log count thing
here it doesn't even visit zero value
cells yeah this is like my just very
quick reference implementation where you
set up the word in the context matrix in
the bias terms you can take the log of
the entire matrix all at once to do that
as a pre computing thing and you could
relate the entire matrix in the way that
I just showed you with F can do that
outside of the loop and then once you
start iterating and working on specific
examples you don't visit the values that
are zero and the reason is because of
that long thing right you would either
have a problem there or you'd want to be
able to say that this is just through
the value of a zero there's no update
for this example
so that's a kind of a definitional thing
about glove but then how is it going to
do when I want it
in the case where here's my count matrix
I've said that wicked and gnarly never
co-occur this is a version of that LSA
example but I made it word by word
because of course love requires a word
by word matrix or a square matrix so how
is it going to do this I kind of hope
that it does have the capacity to do it
actually does anybody have any guesses
there's a lot of detail here but like
what's your hunch it's gonna be unable
to yeah yeah beautifully put that's in
fact what happens I think experimentally
is that what gloves do is push both
gnarly and wicked away from terrible and
torn excellent because it does have
co-occurrence values for them and you're
kind of relying on its ability to do
that in order to achieve this abstract
connection and I think that does happen
so what I did for this little problem is
I just got rid of the bias terms so that
I could display the calculations and I
also started the glove optimization
process in a way that I was sure that
gnarly and wicked were really far apart
so iteration one I basically made them
like to be complete in completely
separate parts of this space
and then I thought what's gonna happen
as I do these updates and building on
exactly your intuition what I've decided
to do is look at what's happening for
both of them as it relates to a sort and
I could have done it for terrible where
you expect them to push away and I
thought that might happen that they they
both gravitate toward excellent and it
does so here's it's kind of small but
this is wicked and terrible and awesome
and gnarly and that's what I meant that
gnarly and wicked or at like opposite
ends of this little two-dimensional
space here and after one integration it
really has been reorganized here's
awesome
here's wicked and here's gnarly and
terrible has been thrust up there into
the corner here and I think if I keep
running
then then Darlene Wickett are just gonna
grab a tape closer to awesome and
farther away from terrible and that's
the sense in which will be capturing
their abstract similarity and then on
the right here what I've done is kind of
color coding is just make that really
concrete so there are the counts up in
the upper left this is the reweighing
this is w0 and the context vector 0 so
that's the starting point and I'm
watching for gnarly and wicked and how
they're gonna get closer to awesome and
when you do that calculation this is
just the derivative of the glove
objective here which I stated up in the
corners you get these error terms and
then that updates the weights and then
after another iteration the error terms
have gotten smaller that is just as you
see in the picture over here these terms
are gravitating toward excellent and you
can imagine that as I go these values
are going to get closer and closer to
zero so I found I found that reassuring
it makes sense any questions I can
answer about it yes awesome that's the
one oh did I excellent up here I did
mean awesome yeah this is myspace gnarly
wicked awesome terrible and I set it up
so that awesome is really frequent and
co-occurs a lot with both gnarly and
wicked and hardly ever was terrible
that's the idea then you can see it
pulling toward the blue those are the
comparisons I keep making and just for
the comment before if I had
uncomfortable comparisons with terrible
I think I would have seen them pull
apart No
gnarly and awesome oh because they're
both positive slang terms right next to
each other in sentences
oh this would be like if I was reviewing
your paper and I like that I would say
it was both gnarly and awesome I'd only
known me for more like your
skateboarding hoops
[Laughter]
there was one more thing just to kind of
fill out my little analytic framework
here so when I showed you all those
relating schemes before I've showed you
before and after on the distribution of
values and here for a glove this is
really nice looking right so the raw
counts come in and they have this really
difficult scaling and then when you
relate with glove that's just raw counts
coming in you wait and you get this like
completely normal distribution here of
cell values and look how nicely they're
scale between negative 2 & 2 and we will
see this I'm going to return to this
point again and again like a lot of the
deep learning models that we look at are
going to be very sensitive to the
scaling of incoming values and you could
just say like this is a really nice
starting point for a lot of those
networks because everything is kind of
scaled in a rational way so this is also
partly why I think love does well as an
input to another system and then I had
some love snippets here just showing you
how to first what I did is just load in
the data frames two of them I had an
eb-5 and I have DB 20 and I just wrote a
little function that would look at the
number of nonzero values that were below
some threshold that I set so that would
be x max and for IMDB 5 it's about 2% of
the values and for IMDB 20 it's 15% of
the values corresponding to the fact
that IMDB 20 has much larger window and
therefore it's much denser because more
things co-occur with other things but
you conceded that is interacting in an
important way with the chosen value for
x max because i've done relatively
little to IMDB 5 by threshold Li but I
did a whole lot IMDB 20 I really made a
lot of those values the same even though
they might have been very different
so something to keep in mind as you use
glob that you might I mean I think I
should have been more reflective on this
in the past in my view slow to think
about the impact of that
perimeter and then for this code snippet
here what I did is just test this idea
the glove objective is to learn word
vectors whose dot product is
proportional to their co-occurrence
count and so you might think that if I
can somehow perfectly achieve this
objective that I'll get a perfect
correlation between the dot product for
two vectors and their co-occurrence and
the original count matrix so I just
wrote a little function correlation test
that does that and I ran glove for a
little while and you can see that the
correlation is about 0.38 for IMDB 5 and
about 0.48 for the IMDB 20 for the
amount that I ran glove I would expect
that value to get larger the longer I
ran glove for but this is a kind of
measure of how much we're living up to
the glove objective and also kind of how
much we're compromising on the original
count matrix it's not that we want to
reconstruct the original count nature so
maybe some loss is useful actually yeah
this slide change I made just one change
I meant to do a shout out for that
somebody noted that I had taken the log
twice it doesn't matter whether you take
it in the line rope rock or roll of prop
and so I just did it on both which was
not good it was affecting the scaling
and since the correlation test that I
chose is sensitive to the scaling of the
values the original correlations were
much higher and I should have been
reflected they were so high that I was
like can that really be right that it's
doing so well this is much more
realistic I thought I would do one more
model here work Tibet I'm just going to
do this one quickly and I can justify
that in part by the fact that the tensor
flu tutorial on word representations of
vector representations of words is
basically an introduction to word to
back and it's really really good so
that's my first practical tip and the
other is that if you want to train your
own word to bet representations then Jen
sim is a nice Python package and it
arbitrarily scalable that you could use
to do that well let me just give you the
gist
this so that you have it in your toolkit
so the fundamental idea that I take it
forward to Beck is that I can take a
corpus and think of it as a label data
set and the way that I can do that is by
setting a window size just the way we
did for all our account matrices and
think of pairs of words that Co occur
within that window as labeled training
instances this is a positive label that
because it was is there in that sequence
then I say it is labeled with was and I
also say it is labeled with that and so
forth for all of these co-occurrence
pairs so it's a funny kind of
supervision right it's not but it's like
a positive example of this word
co-occurring with the other one that's -
yep so it and best do not occur because
they're outside that window that's a
parameter that you would set and the
larger you said it the more training
data you have in some sense of course
it's not all equal so this is the basic
model and you can probably see at the
top here that this is a kind of log
linear softmax classifier you might have
seen this equation before this is the
explicit objective but I think we could
reduce it all the way down to this kind
of blur model here where I have X is my
embedding matrix for the vocabulary W is
some weights maybe we also have a bias
term and then the kind of hard thing to
get used to about this model is that C
is a label vector for an individual
example and it's one column coded but it
has the dimensionality of your entire
vocabulary if you have 20,000 words in
your vocabulary then it's a 20,000
dimensional vector with a single word
having a single dimension having the one
corresponding to the word for that
training instance that co-occurs with
your input word so this is obviously
really difficult to train and it's quite
slow but that's the intuition right
is that I created this label dataset and
then I just do a very standard thing in
machine learning which is have a
classifier that learns to predict those
labels it's just that it happens in this
very high dimensional space will not
take it that's kind of the core insight
behind what's called the skip grande
variant of word to back and then there's
one other thing you might think about is
I kind of I can do this for individual
examples as they come in but if I do it
for my entire vocabulary all at once
that's fine because they're kind of all
independent but when you phrase it that
way you start to see that this is kind
of like another one of these matrix
factorization methods where I have like
my word vector or my word embedding
space and I have my context embedding
space W just like glove did and I'm
taking all those dot products and the
objective of the model is to push those
dot products in a particular direction
and in this case it's in the direction
of favoring the things that co-occur a
lot and it turns disfavoring things that
don't go throw a lot in practical terms
I think people don't use this model
because of the very high dimensionality
of C posting lots of problems so the
more popular version which is
implemented for you in tensorflow
you'll see that in the tutorial is
called skip grande with noise
contrastive estimation and this is a
kind of approximation of that model that
I just showed you where instead of doing
that very high dimensional thing I have
the sum of two separate objectives here
each one of them binary and it's just
saying for the left here those are the
things that actually concur you know
push in that direction and then I sample
some negative instances to be the
negative ones over here and they give
some advice about kind of sample
negative instances but those are
presumably things that you didn't see
coma current in your training data it's
not that they never Co occur it's kind
of a miracle that this works at all
because of course they might be
perfectly both more impaired with the
ideas that on average with a large
corpus when I sample these negative
instances they will be kind of sequences
that are unlikely to appear together and
therefore it's right to
though yeah is there some intuition that
you would want to choose negative pairs
that kind of could appear though where
should you just pick and totally absurd
pair that's an interesting idea
it sounds like something like a linguist
would suggest which is let's think very
carefully about which words are
plausible
I think they don't do that they have
some schemes for sampling from the
frequency distribution which might kind
of align with your intuition but I do
not seem work that tried to get down to
like can this adjective appear next to
this verb or not anyone seen anything
like that it's a potential place for
innovation just because this negative
sampling part really does matter for how
efficiently these model strains get out
okay the final section here retrofitting
the spirit of this is I think it's very
exciting to study distributional
representations and I think they've been
very successful and it's it's kind of
amazing how well it works given that
they operate only on so low current
statistics and large datasets in large
corpora so obviously there are important
aspects of meaning that are latent in
that co-occurrence data but I do not
myself believe the claim that that's all
there is to meaning if I think about
meaning as its studied by linguists or
by cognitive and developmental
psychologists they emphasize other
things beyond co-occurrence like
grounding in a social situation
interaction with other people in the
language all of that stuff that's not
merely co-occurrence but rather about
kind of our entire cognitive lives and
that leads me to doubt that these
distributional representations are going
to tell the whole story of me and a
response that I really like about that
is that we might look to ways that we
could take these distributional vectors
and improve them with some supervision
that is imbue them with information that
wasn't nearly co-occurrence information
that's the pitch of retrofitting and
it's really just one of many methods
that you could adopt for doing that
yeah I've here
given a kind of summary I'd like that
these things are high-dimensional I like
that they're dense and capture lots of
linguistic relationships but I'm
doubtful that we can capture meaning
solely from co-occurrences and I don't
like that there's no grounding you can
leave listen bala question for later not
sure I have an opinion on that but these
two things are the things that I would
really like to address there have been
in the past a bunch of different ways to
do this a bunch of models proposed this
is some work that I did with Andrew Moss
when he was a PhD student here and this
was really just taking distributional
vectors that were learned from a kind of
auto encoder and infusing them with
sentiment information like with the
gradient information from a sentiment
classifier and what we're pitching here
is that you can take this space that's
kind of not well differentiated from
when it comes to sentiment as you can
see by the mixture of colors and kind of
really spread it out sort of the
negative and the positive are in their
own regions and that's coming from the
supervision there are lots of ways you
could do that here's another example
this is actually some stuff that I did
in an exploratory way with more Atsuto
one of our TAS like here I have a kind
of PMI space and if I take that space
and train it against sentiment objective
with a deep classifier and I look at the
hidden representations from that
classifier they of course have shifted
the space around in response to their
supervision and you could see a really
deep sentiment split here with all the
positive and negative words really gone
into their own part of the betting space
these methods can be kind of hard to
tune so I was really excited when I saw
this retrofitting model up here this is
from freaky at all it was an Apple TV I
think one one of the best paper or it's
at metal some kind of pioneering work
and it's implemented in the notebook in
case you want to explore it I've shown
you how to experimental to wordnet and
so forth the gist of this is here the
objective and what I've said here is
that this is an objective that's
balancing two pressures first I want to
be like the original vectors that I've
got that's the pressure in orange but I
would also like to look more like my
neighbors in
oh crap let me unpack that a little bit
let's suppose that you trained a bunch
of representations by whatever methods
you have some vectors for a vocabulary
of English the sense of what you're
retrofitting is that you could find all
of those words say in the word neck
graft just look them up and now you can
imagine that those nodes in that graph
are actually your vector representations
what the retrofitting model does is say
try to remain like those original
vectors but also update them so that
they're more like their neighbors in the
knowledge graph and that's the sense of
mature retrofitting and it's kind of
nice and modular because you can take
any embedding space and as long as you
can grounded in some kind of graph you
can run this objective and move those
vectors around so here's a quick example
in this tiny little graph here this node
0 is related to 1 & 2 2 in the universe
unidirectional fashion when I run
retrofitting you can see that 0 moves
closer to both of them and they stay put
1 & 2 because they're not related back
to 0 that's it it doesn't matter which
direction they go in here's a case where
they're all related to each other and
what you can see with retrofitting is no
matter where they start they're gonna
kind of pull together because everything
is by this graph similar to everything
else because of its connectedness and
then here's one more example there's a
hyper parameter alpha and beta and if
you set alpha to 1 and beta 2 1 then
they're evenly balanced suppose I said
alpha to 0 that's a kind of interesting
edge case where I say I don't care what
the original inventing was like all I
care about is being like my neighbors
and that's the general right because
very quickly they just become identical
to each other with alpha 0 and
conversely if you set alpha really high
then you'll really remain like your
original representations and the graph
will have almost no influence and
between there you might find something
that's kind of usefully making using the
original embedding and also making use
of the knowledge graph structure
yeah where is this knowledge graph
structure like that there is it come
from you need to have it out there in
the world so I gave the example of
wordnet is a case where you have really
easy alignments between whatever
representations you've trained for words
in English and this pre-existing
structure but you can think really
creatively about this lots of data can
be represented in a graph and if you can
find that structure then you can perform
the retrofitting step enough doing some
extensions here one thing that you might
find unsatisfying about the original
retrofitting model is that it's baking
it and very deeply the idea that if I'm
connected in the graph it means that I'm
like my neighbors it's like well one
semantics for these things and this is a
bunch of attempts I was involved with
some of this work to relax that
assumption so for example in wordnet
there is an edge relation for Antonin
and I think it's probably a mistake to
say that just because I'm connected
beyond into that edge but I want to be
similar to that word Anthony has a very
different semantics from for example
cinema which is the dominant kind of
badger hypernym like in tail during tail
5 so these are nice extension to be
released a cone for this middle one this
is kind of the most general version of
biscuit misses this other work tip is
more specialized to rest different
graphical relationships and then here
are a few code snippets I'll let you
look at the notebooks for the full story
because there's some data processing
involved in for example using word net
for retrofitting but here I just gave a
simple example that kind of documents
the interfaces so that you can think
that's it oh that's an inspiring idea to
end on in order to construct the
graphical representation just take like
any set of embeddings and then just sort
of you look at choose K closest
neighbors and then artificially form a
graph that way and then run Oh
interesting so you'd say from the
original space
conduct things that are close by some
standard in the retrofit to them I mean
you can certainly do it it's well
defined I guess I don't know what would
happen I guess that's unusual because I
think of retrofitting has you not have
my inventing space I have some other
resource some other knowledge graph and
you're kind of together I don't know but
you could try it out let's see what
happens yeah what did it's like
retrofitting with wordnet due to the
like analogical relationships does it
preserve those things are made them
better destroy them oh that's a good
question well so in the original paper I
believe they test on Oh analogies
and I think that's one of the tasks that
they evaluate on I should double-check
that they retrofit to wordnet and
framenet
maybe one other grant oh and also yeah a
dataset of paraphrases I'm gonna forget
precisely the experiments that it's an
empirical question how to check the
paper word embeddings holding can we
make some some people think were
awakened love some kind of these are you
trying it for the big yeah the question
was basically whether or not you could
combine forces that is bring a bunch of
different inviting spaces together and
see some gains I think the general
answer is yes and the my thing you might
think about is what's the overall
scaling of the representations that
you're creating are they kind of
harmonized or is it obviously there's
two things that you smushed together and
because that's going to affect how easy
some like later in learning I think the
general answer is yeah pull these things
together if you
at recent papers that use these newer
contextual word representations like
bird and Elmo you might notice that
another number of places they have
actually included the grow-op vectors as
well to have even more dimensions and
even more information brought to the
problem and you see gains in that case
and for the bake-off it's certainly
within balance to smush together all
four of those count matrices or things
that you've done to them see whether
that leads to improvements that's a nice
transition point so what we want to do
now is break no more lecture get
hands-on make sure you can get through
the homework because I think those are
nice preliminary steps to building your
own system build that system and then
you have a big off entry ready for when
we do the announcement on Monday with
their new test sets a few tips we added
to utils a function called fixed random
seeds and you have a bunch of options
for setting random seeds for various
parts of the scientific computing
environment that you're in you might
want to do that for your big off entry
as a way of ensuring that we can exactly
reproduce whatever you got and then you
could have we got a separate discussion
about whether if you if your wind
depends on seed 42 and you don't win
with seed 1 what that means for us but
let's not dwell on that now you might
make use of this function in your kills
you to make it easier for us to
reproduce exactly what you saw and that
is allowed the bake-off is of course
oriented towards the best-performing
system that's the standard thing for
Bake off's but in talking with you I
have come to become interested in two
other questions definitely what's the
worst performing but well-motivated
system we were talking about this
yesterday so not just the
worst-performing system in general
that's not so interesting because you
could just do a bunch of incoherent
stuff like what's the system
really ought to have worked if you think
about the theory that was a disaster for
the problem I really would be interested
in seeing those systems and this is a
kind of grim joke but which systems
consumed the most resources so these
guys have been somebody did trained
below 450 thousand iterations 19 hours
of CPU time and it didn't perform so
well but maybe that gets the award for
most resources consumed so I don't know
if you think you're not going to win
then maybe try something crazy you know
shoot the moon as they say you'll get
full credit for entering I think you're
on your own now so there anything we
should say about how people can connect
with ok just call in and there's some
details on Piazza right yeah we're
available great goodness